alexandre soljenitsyne aura 65 ans le 11
décembre
il est en pleine forme entre deux
longues séances d'écriture
il aime bien se dégourdir les bras au
vrai il n'aime pas rester à ne rien
faire il est toujours en mouvement en
passant sans transition d'un cours de
mathématiques ou d'astronomie à ses
enfants un exercice de bûcheron
il a accepté avec beaucoup de simplicité
et de gentillesse d'être filmé mais pas
question de lui faire tourner de nouveau
une scène écrivain et père de famille da
comédien y est
le soleil du matin tombe en abondance
sur une toute petite chapelle simple
accueillante aux murs tapissés d'icônes
elle est attenante aux salles de travail
de l'écrivain
une des grandes joies des saules génie
jean c'est lorsqu'un prêtre orthodoxe de
leurs amis vient dire la messe pouvait
l'imaginer en arrivant à cavendish que
je verrai l'auteur de l'archipel du
goulag prix nobel de littérature franche
sorte avec une raquette de tennis dans
les annales positif ce court de tennis
ce génie jean l'a fait construire dans
sa propriété le sol recouvert d'un fin
gravier trop mou sur lequel les balles
rebondissent mal peu importe ce sont les
gestes du tennis qui séduit ce génie
jean et la liberté d'y jouer plus que la
compétition il n'a pas l'intention de
s'inscrire à flushing meadow quant à
hyères melet comme ses frères
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils ne préfèrent
pas au tennis le football américain où
le soccer cada beau match et quand
j'étais enfant
yannis tafer rêvé de jouer autonome et
n'y a ni cadavre sur gignac
mais toute ma vie s'est déroulée cette
façon si jamais il ya de quoi non je
n'ai jamais eu d'argent pour acheter
dans la quête a pas tant que ça
l'exposition c'est ainsi qu'il est très
difficile d'avoir accès aux cours de
tennis et la prison
l'énigme la géo vient d'amener les ânes
y arriver voilà j'ai pu me faire un coup
j'ai réussi à jouer ça me donne vraiment
un sentiment de bien-être kanishka que
je fais pas du sport à côté de la maison
familiale
ce génie jean